[Music]
foreign
I've organized a lot of trips where
things didn't go as expected because the
boat was overweight and that's why so
many died there were no life vets or
inner tubes a hundred people lost their
lives in two trips
to stop the loss of life we've
reorganized how we work we've got rid of
the risks that might cause a boat to
sink before we didn't have people who
could read a compass now we look to
assign a captain who knows how to use
one and we don't overload votes anymore
it's all safety first
foreign
to reinsure them and tell them that they
are safe because from there they rise we
realize that we they need the people
that say to them they are you are
finally safe